like everybody was going on play here
welcome it's to collide oh my goodness
oh my we are back here at Comic Con for
another awesome stream today we've got
two very special guests Travis William
and Laura Bailey who's also voiceover
actors for video games and just a good
lucky couple just a great looking couple
finally some good looks in this room
finally welcome guys to join us as
always bet more ass keys in the chat
room with everyone get out of the shot
I'll never get in that shot again and
Jase I'm out of the creeper hi there we
go Wow today we're gonna play little
Diablo 3 and Laura you're in Diablo who
are in that exploit who are you in town
over so I didn't start the game okay my
goodness later on in the game I become a
demon hunter later on in the game you
become a demon huh that's awesome I love
that all right let's go find something
to kill I'm okay so I'm p1 I'm gonna
yell oh I'm the giant spear wielding
with the great dance moves is that a
woman I don't know I think it's a woman
all right where should we head here
where she may know you're following me
let's go yes yeah that's right these
guys are on geek and sundry's critical
role which is which every Thursday at
7:00 on on Twitch you guys can check it
out and that for people who don't know a
critical role is what is critical great
name by the way oh you mean the DM I
know don't we go dragons
that's awesome
I have a must know we're doing the other
half it like never played before
haha we literally don't know we just
come up with things and he's probably
the best improper we ever met and he
just stays in character doing else with
the accent so what's your what are your
name character's name that's awesome oh
my god alright I would be like my name
is Arnie's will a middle schooler drive
if yours can pick on high intelligence
yeah alright let's find someplace to go
a lark I had submitted the team Grogg
Wow cheap drive let's go yeah that's
gonna kill things also if you guys are
if you guys know about Diablo 3 we don't
so tell us where to go and what happen
if it looks like we don't know what
we're doing there's a reason food yeah
we don't we don't exactly somebody said
oh I must have gone to Yale nope just
kids probably how did you guys get into
doing voiceover work we both kind of
start around
oh my god Dragon Ball Z I love joy you
Buffy who are you a positron said oh my
god with the sword that's awesome
actually I don't know I watched it for
years in college we had a bunch of
friends that loved it and then one day I
saw our name in the credits and called
her up that's amazing i wooed her do you
now be voiceover actors do you guys make
the best prank calls or the best prank
I'm just shooting this one dude in the
head over and over Oh be careful those
big those big ones know when you kill
them they explode this guy is like weak
by the way this shooting stood in the
butt that's awesome
and how does it take us through like
what now what you guys do
how long is like a recording session for
video game because there's so many video
games I don't even hear the same thing
right so it's like that can vary it like
you know sometimes it can be an hour or
two hours and you know usually doesn't
go longer than a four hour session just
they don't want they want to keep you
from blowing your voice out yeah
yeah oh wow oh that's great
that's a whole other thing that's
amazing I was pretty trippy yeah they
came to us in they're like we're gonna
make your face in amalgam of you know a
couple different things and then I'm
there of that digital pipeline was done
there like Garrity G crock everybody
knows cries oh yeah that's all you need
is cry I can't do the standard like
walking because there are people that do
yeah how'd you do that I can't do it so
I have very few talents no no I've done
I've actually done voice matching in
movies that's right so voice matching is
where they need somebody to come in and
actually do be do somebody else's war I
whoa all right we just do it awesome
did you also do that I don't know if it
comes through the voice but the lip
biting yeah you're cold yeah exactly
I'm gonna shower just like yeah well
that's how I shower
what do you just you have because your
voice is your life right so what do you
do to protect up you know I mean when
we're doing sessions I mean cigar
absolutely regular intervals no not the
games we have to like yell grenade an
RPG and when you're doing that it's lots
of tea and honey and yeah breaks and you
have to drink lots of water and stuff
what's he are we talking about we talk I
want to get specific natural grain so
yeah some people go I've got a real I've
gotten into a chamomile lately yeah
is this one amazing oh look at that is
what we're doing I'm just laying these
people this guy's got like a rubberband
gun by the way and it is the rope code
yeah is it just like turkey gravy what
is it yeah it's just straight up so do
we know the name of the I knew we were
gonna get to some weird stuff by lucky
named fritz a - or the does the voice of
the whole she's done it three years
awesome nice I play well the middle
school exists you guys are really strong
Fred brings this little bottle it's
y'all you know all the all the
characters on the front or you know have
Chinese and we don't know what it says
this thick Ruby licorice like they get
important to us yeah yeah it's a wooden
bottle and I really like that you can
actually get it to go down it's got this
menthol taste Mike because it's made
with magical kitten we really can't we
ask more like what's in it I let you
walk in on him one day he just pouring
diet coke into like my secret it's my
secret and strangely like others
champions have started to carry it now
you know that it's spreading we can't
Tonga guys exactly
well Matt here oh well Matt's case is
asking traffic can you say I am Groot
you have to have like extra testicles or
something you're always a solo it's
right here whatever so he goes in to hug
Travis is the right stick I just found
it's hot
[Music]
so what's been the most I mean I guess
it's God every project is really fun but
what's that what's the project that's
surprising the most of how fun it was
that's tough you know we really love the
ones where we gets into the mocap for it
as well yeah but when you get to go in
and use your body other suits don't
leave anything to the imagination your
third ball is really sticking out over
you know yeah your shame your personal
shame yeah we we talk with the animators
regular there you go we have a bond and
a trust regiment laugh we now you make
us look much cooler than we are and
that's the cap to the face of yes so if
you if you have some sort of intimate
scene you know where you have to like
get up sometimes real fast you look like
oh no the technology yeah yeah let's go
back to town it looks so bad new to new
Tristram
father ignores oh wait isn't it North is
up sorry I'm leaving will be rolling Joe
don't follow me I don't know what I'm
doing old Tristram Road Tristram Road ah
tortora chant you ask Travis what do you
think of Troy Baker love trippin last of
us
yeah incredible town we got to work on a
far cry 4 together well that's exciting
yeah he played a pagan min and I was his
hired ex-cia a torturer supreme yeah and
I have been buddies for a long time and
[Music]
oh my god that actually kind of brings
up a good point like I can imagine that
the world is is fairly small
ya know like it's kind of so it's a
little bit maybe feels like family
sometimes you do and actually it's kind
of surprising how often we get to work
with our friends yeah Laura and I work
together on a ton of projects but we
have we ever auditioned together in any
capacity yeah like oh it's this you know
fratricide thing good you know you being
together has a perks but why didn't you
talk to it what gives you that idea
oh the guys coming out of the ground why
didn't you talk to them oh but the
Scarecrow doesn't work there we should
be attempting a dialogue I mean it
really close-minded we need like a scary
zombie not a scarecrow what is this oh
I've just got a slightly larger rubber
band yes great question
Jim Cummings the incomparable Frank
Walker of course Mel Blanc Charlie oh my
god I mean you know they're the ones you
always aspire to be something like I'm
sorry
when I first well before I moved out to
California and started working out there
oh yeah I haven't played massive bag no
learn each I started one plus arrived at
the backward compatibility ago there we
go you know what I was just waiting I
was jus biting your that's all I was
just thinking ahead guys
yeah it's super good in engine hail
about this thing this Corp so we know
more kill it kill it dead or make it
more debtor oh that's right yeah cuz we
know no boy you guys are both in Halo 5
and Ronan and II did it was hilarious
slightly boy yeah how do they do better
personally how did they do what the best
part of it was where the developer came
in it started playing let him do it
my favorite was and II was like pointing
us you know looking at the ground
looking straight up TJ it's just like
them both I love it go pillage montage
kid trucks is in the house I don't want
to do any of my range the textures I
don't make it so but you guys if you
guys are just joining us our with Travis
William and Laura Bailey - awesome
voiceover now we are also can be seen on
geek and sundry's critical role every
Thursday night at 7:00 on Twitch and so
you but you guys work we were saying
before you'd never play D&D before ever
no thing and so I mean what do you think
how's it going it was so random because
we got together for a friend's birthday
party that's how you know what you could
be it you could be talking about smoking
crack it's just gonna be one quick first
drawing the first ones rate one rock
yeah we're gonna smoke half a rock being
with you know naturally nerdy and geeky
people in our business we had we had had
people that had played and they had told
I don't know it sounds so cool they have
done it for charities and stuff yeah
this one off
and it was just six voice shout oh whoa
whoa
head seller and we got together started
playing I showed up late and I walked
into a room where she is speaking in an
accent flirting and haggling over prices
and I got asked what my name was like
the friend of Monkey Island and I go
aaaghh and two years later we still the
same characters saying if your character
died I mean you don't do that if your
character dies you dad what are you
doing it's serious so sorry everyone
yeah I mean after two years I can
imagine the game I have this I have this
bear companion because you know yeah Oh
a bear pan Yin Oh what what you're here
what's your bear companions names drink
it yeah is that like ironic like you
call it big guy tiniest trinket like a
huge in the game my twin brother's name
okay okay he's a he's a rogue and so he
steals one thing uh-huh
so I was always seeing these people and
so I went on my own ah perfect
that's awesome but yeah I'm supposed to
fight with him that's like the whole
purpose of having one of those things
right right but I love him too much that
I always keep him next to nothing with
him and I'm useful
she safeguards the bear although I did
almost hit him killed once he was moving
you were being too cautious with him
through a minefield and I slapped him on
the ass with my giant battle axe and he
almost hit every mine on the way my
couch that night I know that's true you
guys got to leave you guys don't leave
it to tomorrow right you bring it home
there bring it into the room yeah
trinkets save VAX from the lava somebody
said all right there we go I like it I
like it I didn't think I was there I had
been kidnapped because I'm so happy
he hasn't exploded I'm just hitting him
with my hammer of justice and I was that
it's a justice hammer you got a deal
Justin it is now I think your name is
ham-hawks by the way I had a guy named
beef but he got killed everybody was
like beef with 13 E's but I shouldn't be
allowed to have a child because I feel
like I just named my child something
like visa for something awesome or like
oh I'm sure there's gonna be no bad guys
in this CATIA always terrible terrible
oh how do you recharge
I don't know after all I think oh I was
out of
let's go down in this thing your [ __ ]
mated with your crossbow oh god here we
go
number one for people who want to people
watching this wanting to kind of get
into what you guys do what are what are
some tips I mean like I mean it is kind
of it's that the great thing about you
know like it being a small world is that
you guys know everybody but I would say
the hard thing is like how do you break
into that sweepstakes drinking the cat
juice they're really awesome and we both
got our started in anime back in in
Dallas which we always kind of call the
boot camp of acting but you can do that
you can match the clouds to the Japanese
guy is that like kind of the most
challenging thing you guys have tried to
do I mean there's a sweet nodding
money's guys there's this guy's even way
too many carbs did he's on he's on bread
and cut up yeah every cut out the gluten
bro what are you doing any skill level
that comes with dubbing and it just lets
you polish your skills so then we
actually get something where it's you
know you can your performance is free
yeah it just it just allows you to draw
from the deeper skill reservoir I guess
you are oh yeah
oh really yeah like maybe videotape
yourself a recording never gets is
really in video games right and the
script is always changing I'm sure thing
is that with with computers and
microphones being you know cheaper and
and recording software being more
available on yeah like it's so easy for
people to practice mimicking things that
they like a lot of us are really good
mimics you know if there's a character
you like or a voice that you think that
you're you're good at or could imitate
yeah and practice that and just see what
kind of flexibility your voice has yeah
like kind of play to your strengths a
little totally yeah I mean you got to
experiment with it that's that's really
all that we do people feel like we you
know I've got these things now at the
beginning of any session is just like 20
minutes of us doing absolutely
ridiculous voice nice and try not to
sound like an idiot that's cool I mean
and that's actually really good to hear
because like you know as someone who's
not not into voice in over industry at
all I would be extremely nervous going
into audition yeah I mean there's a room
at 10 people on the other side of the
soundproof glass that are judging you
right look the soundproof glass like how
horrifying is that there's a [ __ ] yeah
there's a button you know they press
this button for you to be able to hear
what they're talking about when they
depress the button all alone you gotta
have pretty good self-confidence I mean
I'm not even kidding it's just like
there are at least confidence in your
ability it's a little dramatic motion
for yourself at least in your abilities
Oh see
yeah my dad died that's like my job is
dying
good job lanterns that means we have to
kill something else right away why are
we so glowy right now I think you guys
have some kind of power up you stumble
bit can I drink a potion I want to get
like really potion drunk right how many
shitty you mean that potion yo I hit the
table and I blew it out is that bad tell
her over 85 nice and I have a specific
set of skills it's gonna be so great to
like to be able just to be out of the
bar if somebody ever he gives you any
crap just to use like oh excuse the
double kick or they'll just hit you
right away
right big fan man you talk to me the
weird voice man that was cool man
I'll have a Shirley Temple extra
cherries cherry might sound like your
own I love it what are some video game
video game sagas you guys would love to
be a part of you guys are just fans of
you would love your voices you I mean we
are extremely Kiki yeah they're our
favorites you know like we love Game of
Thrones we love Star Wars oh yeah she's
killing it right into the third ball I
don't think I will yeah just write that
third ball right there file where is
yeah I was fortunate to get to be a part
of the Dragon Age position
oh that was great we played with we
played a pretty procedure came in not
have made out just depending on whether
or not my husband's I have to say it was
super weird her romance it was very
weird hearing that voice come out of
Freddie Prinze jr. right very weird it
was it was great it was great and you
can actually see that on our past
broadcast on twitch.tv but uh but yeah
it was very weird it's like I'll never
forget either like you know such a big
fan of beavis and butt-head and seeing
my judge on Letterman right doing the
voices he's just great a closer mom
crazy it blows your mind yeah that was
the thing like when I was a kid I firmly
believe that lion-o all of the Voltron
yeah yeah real people yeah it was it was
a real thing if I had known that there
was some a human person responsible for
that I would have been heartbroken I
remember in the beginning days of
Napster I downloaded some of some
bloopers some Thundercat orders anyways
oh my god like mom knowledge oh my lord
oh my god it was great you're like snarf
oh god it was great it's a shame there's
not room for more bloopers because the
stuff that goes on in some of the
live-action reporting oh I can only
imagine yeah
so do it you're all in detention and our
poor director is just trying to wrangle
so you guys actually do get to work with
groups it's a video play style oh that's
right yeah that's great cuz I I've heard
a lot like like many times you're only
like Anna Ivan happens image of it being
like at a booth with one spotlight
yourself
sometimes it is but with animation a lot
of times you get your report that's it
I know that chemistry is important so
like Roger Craig Smith plays Captain
America Troy Baker plays Hawkeye so
we'll be in there throwing pencils at
each other's crotch is because it's a
different thing when it comes from all
right there's like a different a more
finely okay we're trying we're trying to
keep you at work yeah where we take that
Dragon spawn touch my friends I have two
Spears and no range Jase I saw that
everyone shall I act like audio cut out
one minute very funny you're just gonna
hit them where it hurts right in the
third ball of the soul yeah nice try
fading cake I know you guys are doing
whatever by the way yeah if you guys are
gonna try to troll us don't put it on
the chat agencies my god we can read it
although great idea it was a funny it
was a funny idea could it be possible
where we are the three greatest warriors
that are possible likely I'm just saying
we don't leave tables standing we don't
leave enemies alive
what do you guys looking forward to the
most is your come come oh man so Batman
vs Superman any kind of like sneak peeks
or trailer so though I want to see it so
bad yeah see good as well as the Marvel
kid but what do you think of Ben
Affleck's Batman voice I know you made
yeah but it's all digitized you're right
your education
I'm super curious to see how Jason Momoa
is gonna do is Aquaman like how the
whole just like comes together that's
gonna be awesome it's kind of how many
Comic Cons have you guys been to you
guys are old hat at this old hat I know
this year is it's a little prayer I've
been a couple times before we follow who
planned this dungeon this is terrible
what the red thing I could jump dude I
didn't know we got to walk around this
way okay Arnon gonna be come from that
way following cross we came in that way
to sit down came from now and spit out
no wait Liza let's go that way holy crap
I can't tell you guys this is unreal
yeah it's like our sixth year where we
Petco Park it's just awful
oh yeah do you need a pass to get over
there thanks I love it so where could be
but if people aren't San Diego where can
they find you down here halo panels this
morning so that's done awesome that's it
on the streets that's right on the
streets happy taking pictures of you and
you can find these guys on Twitter and
Instagram Laura Bailey vo and willing
blam I am the best the night that
Twitter my buddy was like don't make it
add willingham make it really bland well
employ one cup of bourbon of like you
got it I love it and check out halo five
and of course critical role on geek and
sundry every Thursday night at 7 and
that airs on Twitch yes Oh check that
out thank you so much Lord Bailey I
don't hit that third ball I don't want
to hit that dirty bomb he's good a
little clip oh I love it
alright here we go now our next guest
we're very excited come on in Michelle
[Applause]
right good to see you guys hello what's
going on Michelle Marlo from Nerdist is
here Oh Michelle we were just on a panel
last night where we killed it tingles we
did tails we had we'd to pick what was
that we had to pick our two favorite
superheroes there are two favorite
videogame characters to go up against
each other protagonist protagonist I
picked Super Mario and Master Chief you
picked the Dark Knight in the Dark Lady
and who won Amelia
no Amelia won I know between us I think
there was more clapping for me I think
there was more clapping for me I think
that's a southern clap I think there's a
solder it's inside one sad man clapping
so we are gonna put like we're playing
diablo 3 reaper of souls oh you are a
I'm guessing you know everything there
is to know I don't know anyway wait
we're gonna kill one of these guys we're
gonna get one of these guys out of here
oh did you where's our other person
they're gone
oh there's just a to know here we go how
do we get rid of get rid of this person
right here this guy sucks by the way I'm
playing the entire time I don't know
what he is he's sexy he's very much like
me he'll look at that but yeah how do
you zoom in can i zoom in a cage going
on like he's goblin king like labyrinth
David Bowie style exactly what's the
ball over the ball over the ball I love
it I love it how do I get rid of you're
smart how do I get rid of this guy do
you know I don't want to play him
anymore the sexy guy or should I play
with this sexy guy the sexy guy sucks
all right fine all right normally you
know it's interesting like I normally
play Diablo on PC
of course yeah you're a big PC I don't
even I just got a PC you did yes and
don't be mad at me don't be mad at me
I'm so proud don't be mad all right the
drop shot here we go all right all right
I'm sexy man I hope you're happy
okay where are we alright we're gonna
kick you out you know what we gotta go
up this one we just found out with
Travis and Laurie we just found this big
blue hole there's the blue hole I feel
like you know we're just very beginning
with the very good day yeah even see
we're just at the blue hole you have any
fun
whoo we wouldn't be seen yet you know
have you run into daiquiri yet with this
whole thing thicker came know who's
Deckard Cain who I don't know anything I
don't know anything
who's I don't know anything who is
hashtag sexy I'm guessing that was for
me hashtag sexy exactly hashtag who is
decade um Michelle what are you doing
down here at comic-con and who do you
think you are Oh No what are you doing
down here at comic-con I'm doing a lot
of things they are we you are you are
the busiest woman I think I've ever
really yes guys will be evidenced by the
90 things you're about to say let's hear
it I am working for Nerdist of course I
did the Nerdist gaming panel you guys
have an amazing installation over Petco
Park why thank you very much we hold in
activation activation directive ation
and I highly suggest anytime you can use
the word activation did you guys come
from that door back I'm here we came
from this way this is the test of your
skills more all right yeah so we're
working for Nerdist do the gaming panel
this morning I was working for Skybound
I oh my god how'd you guys not pick up
this in blue I know I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry
Michelle's losing respect for me the
more we play this game I'm really gonna
whoa like that how did you do that I
just crushed seven items put that in
your pipe is smoking
pick up that gold we have kind of
treasure goblins all right so let's lie
down I interviewed the Patrick Fugit oh
this morning how did it go it was
awesome
he is the he's the star of outcasts if
you guys haven't read the comic outcasts
yet so the new Robert Kirkman amazing
comic it's amazing it's about demonic
possession it's so sick
I mean being that we're playing Diablo
it's like a perfect Madea what is it a
demonic possessions and what do you mean
I know I know I think one of us is gonna
get possessed by the time Comic Con is
over a lot of people don't know that
Diablo 3 this is actually I'm named
after Diablo Cody this game no that's at
the end the final level is you have to
write the sequel to Juneau and it's
weird it's weird it's like an essay
question you have to send it in it's
really weird I know who's sorry spoiler
alert for those of you haven't got the
last level of Diablo 3 very intense I
don't know where you guys came from
necessarily but let's go I guess we're
just gonna go wrap we're just to join
the architecture look beautiful it is I
think this place could use more rugs hey
it's very cold and damp you know get the
dehumidifier down here it's true no the
loos right this rug is rotting this is a
beautiful tapestry it's being it's
rotting exactly it's the worst article
in the how many at Comikaze event - this
is like your 90th probably probably not
India yeah you're about right and what
are some wonder if we put if people are
watching and this is their first
comic-con
what do you have some advice for the
fridges it's my first comic kind of down
here what are all these people in these
costumes and where do I go what do I do
I say just to get the Mackay maximum
enjoyment can we swear what's to do
swear swear away just like smoke some
weed and walk smoke some weed that's by
the way not a swear word
none of those what you just said we're
swear words I always do that I psyched
myself out from it she's like did I say
swear word
yeah sure you should drive a Prius Shh
my dope yours only look here okay
shrine buffering shrine brush I mean
like I think you just gotta go see you
later a rare to buy everything you want
to go look at like just go do it go do
it
everything how long would kiss whoops
how long wait a long time in line for
panels they do so if you're smart and
you have like a 3ds and you're playing
your food you should StreetPass straight
pass it up I'm so pissed I didn't bring
my 3ds - StreetPass are you three are
you I'm dumb I'm a dumb person you
already know I was in person I bought a
book of jerk I brought a book of German
poetry but I didn't bring my three yeah
I know it's a proper thing to get into
twitch stream guys where do we go
somebody help us out all right
and so that's kind of good what are some
things you're doing oh yeah so told me
for what how to enjoy the proper down
here yeah man you wanna do stuff there's
a bunch of stuff over at Petco Park that
you can go and just be a part of you
don't have to have a badge for that so
one of the coolest things that I'm doing
that I'm super excited about massively
fangirling over for every Blizzard fan
that's here apparently in the audience I
get to interview the cast of the movie
Warcraft yeah park with the director
Duncan Jones I'm super stoked
awesome David Bowie's son I know spawn
of Bowie's spawn of Bowie directed moon
which is amazing with Sam Rockwell love
that movie thing are we just going back
out I'm not sure where you
exactly can't remember but you went to
north and west and you were saying
alright we're going down literally going
down to Colleen's going down oh here we
go there's something bad over here I
think so yeah oh yeah how do we get I'll
get on there so yeah and I think that's
dreams to cast a board - yes watching
that's awesome and I'm playing a live
game a superfight tomorrow as well
that's gonna be fun do you get now you
you you obviously participate in
tournaments and things like that yeah
you get nervous playing like
competitively in front of an audience my
god you know I thought I would wait for
the mayhem begins event for heroes of
the storm oh my god
and I hadn't played like against real
gaming professionals not like you know
not self-proclaimed not like youtubers
necessarily like that like but I did
plays Smosh games and it was like Matt
sohinki that was on the panel last yeah
yeah those guys and we won that's
awesome I mid lanes with like some son
like pro gamer playing Muradin and it
was sick I was like I can't believe I'm
actually winning we want did you feel
like a professional athlete I crowd
going wild do it up like that man oh man
yeah so I've never felt that way it was
cool because I did the espn2
heroes of the dorm of nth whoa that's
what was that it was the first live
collegiate video games on television
that's crazy yeah and so is a big
college tournament let's go this way
alright I'm gonna follow you by the way
your name is ham hocks I'm sorry I
didn't name it I didn't name you I might
have made you
I don't remember here's a while ago
wooden barricades slashed just a bunch
of crap somebody left behind and forgot
to clean it up oh I see
all right
in bottom left here we go yeah yeah so
maybe we don't have the 360 cams set up
for dos I don't watch other people play
and so I didn't get a plane myself so
being able to play at the YouTube stages
was my first like playing playing and I
was that was a little nervous but I mean
what did you learn from playing from
playing competitively against those guys
did you pick up Annie Taylor trihard is
a secret try harder what's bad it was
you know it's like I like it
I'm just casual gamer no big deal right
Liam I don't want a [ __ ] would that
you're very competitive I use finally
yeah driving that Prius I do drive a
Prius it's good it's it's very
environmentally conscious you're
environmentally conscious badass I
driving big into like destroying
environments yeah they want us to
destroy that's why they made it yet
probably makes them happy what are you
doing the whole time lately
yes this year for the fans we're doing a
show it's awesome tonight we have oh
hell yeah so nice we have both the Game
of Thrones cast and the cast of The
Walking Dead on so there's gonna be like
that was it people here it's very
exciting we're very pumped yesterday we
had the the gay The Hunger Games cast
here is fantastic
oh my god Liam Hemsworth dreamy so three
those eyes you just want to [ __ ] you
want to take a bath in those eyes you
know a bathroom just a bath in them just
I don't know how that's even possible
but it'd be awesome Jase hashtag bad
word
let me see pancake is that is it does
that creep rollin
creeper on pre-parole lane we're doing
here well looks like we gonna go this
way so are you a I do play DD I do play
Travis said Travis Taylor are talking
about they've got a geek it's under they
that critical role situation a friend of
mine Matt Mercer when you play what are
some of the characters you like playing
I like witch doctor witch doctor is
totally my character for Diablo 3 yeah
that's why why because it's cathartic
cuz you can sing that side it's away
from me I want to do you know you don't
like to bring this by God
are you afraid spiders in real life yeah
really I hate space my mom's always like
no we gotta save on like save this Black
Widow no save this blue no where are you
hanging out that there's all these black
widows in Washington State yes
oh sure it's Spokane yes okay nice book
cat yeah you remember I was there on to
earth Conan by the way I saw it I don't
know how deep we want to go into deep -
blaze stories I want there I there was a
ghost in my room it's a book yeah why oh
you stayed at the Davenport well then
that make sense I know have you ever
heard this story I don't know if the
chats of her but I'm aware of it yes yes
tell me
alright get a quick quick story quick
story we're there too or were there for
our two nights I believe and and I
didn't know anything about the deaf or
deaf born is an old hotel it was built
in like the 20s or 30s yeah and it looks
out very cool gorgeous hotel and now
they have like it's now expanded to its
larger but there's still a part of the
three old anyway we're there and now I
will get scared
the only thing scares me is like talking
to a girl in the bar I don't get scary
my life darkness I don't get scared by
you know whatever but that in color
Brian scares purse he's very tall and
he's very strong he's very tall very
tall and so anyway so it's nighttime and
in my room and all of a sudden out of
nowhere I get super scared like like I'm
not scared and then like super like a
switch like a switch right and among us
I don't know nothing nothing I was just
laying there no nothing and I was just
laying there he's got super scared know
what's going on like WTF bleh
I call myself play in my mind and and
ucw said I say WTF yeah it's weird I use
hashtags in my great what time's dinner
and then I kind of look over and I start
to get the feeling that there's like
something by the window okay and I'm
looking over I realize we're not like a
like this little boss right here and all
these guys are like just destroying us
yeah they're killing us is killing me
killing me
Oh personally your resurrect I'm dead we
go and so I start thinking oh and I look
over to the window and there's like you
know come windows and one window in the
corner is like there's a the curtains
like moving a little bit just like a
little bit like this oh it's the air
conditioning whatever is there in
conditioning whatever but I start I'm
stuck like I'm really afraid like I'm
like oh there's like it feels like
there's like something over there my god
I was like dude you gotta chill out like
whatever like you know what this is this
is [ __ ] I'm gonna get up and I get
up and I go over to the thing there's no
air blowing on the curtain and I'm like
what the hell and I grab the curtain I
let it go and it stops moving I was like
huh and I jump back a bit I'm like huh
I'm laying in bed and all the sudden
there's like these weird noises like
weird like whistles and clicks and pops
and stuff come from like the ceiling uh
my god ah so I put out my Beats
headphones I just turn up the Drake and
whatever I go sleep okay use ignored it
I ignored it and I just I kept listening
to music till I fell asleep right I was
really freaked out and again I don't get
scared
alright next day I'm walking with you
might have no hurt Debbie wonder she
works at Nerdist she books in talent for
the dirties now so I feel like I know
for like talking dead so yeah and what
Debian are walking back to the hotel and
I'm telling her this story i'm like oh
it's so stupid like or whatever and she
was like haha we can't she's like have
to stop at the front desk and we go to
the front desk for whatever and I'm
telling her he kind of the end of the
story and I was like oh and I was scared
and the guy without hearing the other
stories like oh he's like it's like yeah
you um you see ghosts last night I was
like no no and he's like he's like
you're on floor 18 right in the back and
I was like yeah and he goes yeah then we
have a haunted hotel and I was like
hahaha well done Debbie you this is
funny this is a funny joke like you
think it's like I think yeah I think
they're like putting me out because
we've work at a comedy show and I opened
my heart to someone and so I thought
they were lucky and like you guys like
no and then another guy comes out of the
back and kind of over here so she's like
oh yeah Florentine in the back I was
like yeah he's like yeah like what's
your room like 18 35 or 36 I was like
yeah it's like 1831 he's like yeah the
haunted beaver haunted what he's like
google it and sure enough the Davenport
is a haunted hotel and it's known for
being haunted
especially that floor and he and he told
me a story of this woman that apparently
he's like go he's a go look out your
window and I guarantee you look down on
the glass la because apparently she
jumped out or killed herself the glass
lobby and you know fell through the
glass lobby and I'm like okay funny joke
guys whatever I'm going up to my room
and I'm super freaked out at this point
yeah I go up there and I look out of the
window and sure enough out of that
window glass ceiling of the lobby and I
was like oh my god and it was a super
freaked out and then and so then I'm
like all right I'm just gonna turn the
TV whatever and this is 100% true I turn
the TV this shining is on no yeah I even
just to because I knew no one would
believe me so I immediately grabbed my
laptop and I recorded on YouTube
do you do really yeah so I just just so
I could like net prove to people that I
wasn't totally crazy insane insane all
these things why you tell it's a story
zone now do you believe in ghosts
Michelle Moore absolutely I've been to
the Davenport I got scared shitless yeah
we went there for prom oh my god
ghost prom goes brother I said a ghost
prom
yeah that's pretty house the place to go
was exciting way back were you there
when they had all like the Safari area
are here who's running the Davenport
they got ghosts in like animals safaris
yeah they have like a little animal
Safari area you walk down there's a bar
and then like there's all these like
stuff tigers shoots no and that's scary
he's like I think someone sounds like a
lot of hear me kind of freaks yeah
sounds like someone's driving a Prius
that's crazy
that's right you guys are just joining
us with Michelle more of Nerdist to fire
at Michelle amaura one L 1 l a--
Michelle that's my mom's fault two O's
two R's two M's my brains broken I've
always been like it's like tomorrow
good morrow that's right yes I feel like
big kids until it's your record they're
actually I took a picture he's in shock
where they said hail on the morrow so I
for it appear on my head and I was
kicked out I basically did yeah why so
yeah I love red fares rent here so one
it's one other thing
I look forward to most every year in Los
Angeles where's my question everyone
goes to the Ren Faire to get the giant
Turkey oh right is that coming out the
window everyone gives a giant turkey leg
right there answer why don't they just
why don't they just sell giant turkey
legs in real life I don't know is there
some conspiracy is that the only reason
why the rent first still exists is so
people get their turkey legs
I feel like I feel like we could get you
what I don't know I don't think so Comic
Con I challenge you bring me a giant
turkey leg bring it to me and put it in
my mouth and let me eat it and then take
it away from me
I challenge you one of our friends with
a group from Meredith he's walking
around with the turkey leg just like
drunk and he's just like using it as a
point there was a weapon I could use a
Diablo 3 a giant turkey yeah aah Grizz
standard Jordan is downstairs watching
rehearsal but he did show up earlier
this week he didn't show up brothers do
George slansky is a associate producer
on our show no one actually knows what
he does here he's a little a little
creepy he's got a stare that looks like
he might you know alleged murder I don't
know I know I took that by Jordan except
for when it except for when I do all the
time but now Jordan didn't come by the
stream earlier in the week but right now
he's just doing TV I don't know oh man
Chris kumis and his team are art
direction oh yeah oh my god we there was
we've got the windows open up here in
the offices we're in the Spreckels
theater yes and there's a huge bang
yesterday and everyone's like oh my god
I looked out on the street I never
second there was like an exploded like
r2d2 we're like oh my god what happened
and then we saw our special effects guy
it was us we hadn't exploded we're just
shooting something
like oh of course we're idiots who else
would it blow up an r2d2 in the street
bunch of psychopaths yeah there's a lot
of people out there that's a very angry
and nerds right now have you seen any
what's your bet have you seen any good
costumes this year
I saw Gumby yesterday Wow that'd be
awesome
yeah he was like a really like low-rent
Gumby's what we should be yeah he was
just kind of like I mean he had the
costume Astaire was like you know he was
depressed Gumby and pokey was nowhere to
be found
Oh what happened yeah out of work Gumby
Jon Snow we said water Jon Snow that
just said resume oh there we go
there we go it is crazy like are you a
big Game of Thrones fan so it's
separated a lot from the books obviously
I mean Jon Snow right yeah he doesn't
he's not dead is that true Touche Touche
although he lost a lot of blood that's a
lot of blood or maybe he had just he was
carrying like a big bag of chocolate
sauce in his backpack and we didn't see
it underneath his cape and then when he
fell down at all spilled out I mean
that's probably what happened that's
what I'm guessing that's how they do
knowing George our part in the movie
yeah that's how they do spoiler alert
that's right basement jack basement Jack
you read these things absolutely my
research Michelle that's right you also
oh by the way uh you should wait for
hello giggles or still do I used to used
to there are times I do when I like
there we go you've been performing you
been in front of the camera I mean yeah
like I host Blizzcon which is
that's right you've been in front of the
camera and behind the controller hell
yeah that's right exactly where you want
to be that's awesome but you know being
a big horror movie fan what are some of
the newer horror movies to your side but
did you see it follows oh girl
Oh first of all they shot in Michigan in
my hometown my home stage yeah yeah it's
really great and scary I I don't know
how you feel but the things that scare
me the most are porcelain dolls wells
yeah sure yes all those things but I
don't get like the jump out scares don't
get me like the creepy is getting like
the shining very scary totally scream
not scary no you don't know saying like
that's but so it follows it's very
simple you know it's the ring terrified
rings terrifying very very creepy so I'm
kind of I'm actually really excited for
for outcast to come out yeah does it get
no I haven't read it does it get crazy
bloody you know it's demonic possession
so I mean it's this kid who is
struggling with this demonic possession
his entire life yeah um but you know I
don't want to spell a whole lot but what
I'll tell you guys is that his journey
is that he's kind of trying to figure
out why he has this power to fight
demons and why the hell demons are kind
of suddenly around yeah like maybe he
changed bodies to me maybe he changed
his Axe body spray and they really like
this house no maybe TVs just love the
twin dragon sense exactly
try not to think about Axe body spray
hippodamus even exactly yeah
Jim the dragon thai in japanese scary
movies in general agreed notice guys i
don't know what's going on over there in
those countries but they know how to
make a scary horror movie we saw one
recently that
really kind of cool indie movie hey what
was it honey what was a call it was
she's talking to Noah by the way she's
talking to she's a demon friendly oh
yeah a girl a girl walks home alone at
night fantastic
weirdly that was creepy by an Iranian
director but shots in California Oh
shucks yes very weird right you would
think I was like oh it's just like
amazing like pinup psycho all I kept
thinking is like nothing better happen
to that cat yeah I know I know I know
how agree yeah it's a great that you
should grow up someone like that nothing
happens to the cat but it's a it's a
really great indie movie about kind of
this vampire in like a small town it is
super creepy it's awesome yeah that and
it follows work where great follows this
amazing actress what's her name again
cuz she's in house of cards she's in
blacklist
I don't know she's in everything right
now she's incredibly blowing up as the
kids say just blowing up Frances with
you you do yeah that's you and that's
your apprentice Oh is mine yeah you just
got a you got a fan Oh No please sign an
autograph please
yeah so Travis and Laura we're just on
here talking vo and talking me out yeah
it's awesome they were very very cool
I just booked my first big VL role whoa
nice give me some tingles this summer
I'm do these tangles vo roll let's hear
it what is it I'm a the new voice of
Alleria Windrunner in hearthstone wow
that's awesome
well done cool and and when do you start
recording or have you I already did is
that awesome and how long how long your
skin so if you have it's it's a
purchasable skin okay you don't need it
you don't have to buy it but no no don't
don't ever say you don't need I mean you
need you don't need it in order to play
and win the
you can still play as as as Rex are the
hunter which is Matthew Mercer's Master
Matthew Mercer's voice that's awesome so
yeah I can't they get it right now can
they ten bucks but it's like it's a
vanity skin and like I'm all about
vanity so you know we should totally buy
it who is it it's really fun and I'm a
big hearthstone player so it's kind of
weird to be able to talk [ __ ] in the emo
yeah absolutely my own voice to be like
that's right that's emotionally crushing
it's weird when I'm actually doing I'm
like thinking nobody knows this is
actually me talking [ __ ] to them I just
started playing hearthstone and I have
to say which daiquiri plans I'm just a
the standard deck but it's dangerous
because it's on my phone so James it's
yeah it's nice perfect she learns quick
learns quick but it's dangerous because
I have my phone with me all the time you
don't have a saying like it's that I
might have to I might have to get rid of
it because we should go for it
are we going back out wait me to go down
down baby
thank you it's dangerous to have a game
on my phone I kiss like you know candy
all those games like it you can't I've
said this before but I can't just smoke
half a crack broccoli when you start
playing that's it you're just into it
and you're into it forever so it's
terrible candy crush is an interesting
game the way that they that they did it
I feel like I'm very smart about their
in-app purchasing as much as everybody
gets really pissed off about it yeah
give me I'm not like the girl to tend on
the vanity skin I hate in game
purchasing and she's just like a little
too much because like you can't keep
playing right the problem with it like
with something like hearthstone you can
keep playing the game yeah yeah I don't
feel like keep buying into yeah it
doesn't force you to do
the circle and we had also mine the
diamonds really fun we had Toby Turner
on the best Tobuscus is the best yeah I
saw you met packs Lester being linked to
the side of my face there we go
perfect he was like when I get that
checked out it's like oh no what's on my
cheek now or maybe no you superpowers
you can't be cut by more the more
knowledge that might explain how you can
talk to demons that's fantastic so let's
go stand by yes Tobuscus was here and he
said he gave us a is that you or me
that's you uh actually this might be a
good time day it's one o'clock oh yeah
what I guess where are you one killed so
we slay a slave we do on top then we do
down below
ladies and gentlemen Michelle Moore oh
you can find her what else can people
find you know all the social media at
Michelle Morrow one L do weekly show
with Nerdist you can find me Wednesday
running the Warcraft guild and I'm
hosting let's go I get that deal see
skin for our stuff yeah beautiful voice
it could suit you going to sleep look
wow that was pretty great alright thank
you guys for joining us who see you
tomorrow I knew with more special guests
and watch Conan tonight at 11:00 on CBS
The Game of Thrones cast and The Walking
Dead cast who knows what's gonna happen
it's amazing it's gonna be crazy die
that's right where your diapers you're
gonna bleed out of your brain in a good
way in a good way I promise you alright
see you guys later